welcome to the League of Legends
champion spotlight featuring yawa the
unforgiven who says I can't handle my
drink Yasuo is a melee fighter on the
hunt for his elders killer the only
swordsman in his generation to have
perfected a legendary wind technique
Yasuo directs the currents themselves to
dash through enemy front lines and
nullify range threats with zero cost
abilities and extremely low cooldowns
Yasuo thrives in extended teamfights and
relies on his high mobility to engage in
shred through his enemies Yassa woes
passive way of the wanderer has two
components the first intent doubles
Yahshua's critical strike chance so
building fifty percent crit on Yafo
means the tax always critically strike
the second component in yaso as passive
is resolved yah suppose resource bar his
flow is replenished through movement the
faster Yasuo moves the faster he refills
is flow if Yasuo takes damage from enemy
champions or neutral monsters while his
flow bar is full he converts his flow
into a shield for a few seconds yah
suppose a sweeping blade affects several
of his other abilities so let's start
there sweeping blade is a single target
dash that damages and marks yas woes
enemy signaling that he cannot dashed
them again until the mark is dissipated
sweeping blade has a fixed distance so
if he's standing close to his target
he'll dash through it each successive
cast deals increased damage up to a cap
so it's advantageous to dash through
several targets at a time to maximize
your damage output unlike most dashes
sweeping blade can be interrupted by all
crowd control effects when caught
overextending the ostwal can use
sweeping blade to dash through enemies
toward the safety of his turret next up
is yo suppose Q steel tempest after a
brief channel Joshua thrust this sword
out in the direction of your cursor
damaging all enemy units hit steel
tempest functions as a basic attack
meaning yossel concret with it and he
applies on hid effects to the closest
struck enemy
if Yasuo cast steel tempest three times
in a row his third cast sends out a
long-range whirlwind that damages and
knocks up all enemies in a line in Lane
steel tempest is ya s'pose
bread-and-butter ability with its low
cooldown he can use his cue to last hit
and her ass as he build stacks toward
his whirlwind by catching the ability so
frequently he's able to use the na
couple an extra attacks on kha'zix Yasuo
can also activate steel tempest while
dashing with sweeping blade when used
mid dashed the ability slashes all
enemies immediately around him if he
dashes with sweeping blade while hitting
his third to you yes will also knocks
them up into the air wind wall has a
passive and active component passively
it increased the rate at which dashing
replenishes gas oppose flow barb
activating the ability instantly sends
out a wall in a target direction that
blocks all enemy projectiles for a few
seconds including ranged Auto attacks
skill shots and targeted abilities the
only projectiles of the wall doesn't
stop our turret attacks still win vault
is an extremely powerful ability with a
potential to block tons of damage when
time to position correctly cast wind
wall behind you while retreating from
range enemies to ensure a successful
disengage
yah swells ultimate his last breath
which has an enormous cast range but can
only be used on airborne enemy champions
activating last breath teleport eos bow
to his target suspending them in midair
briefly while he deals physical damage
to them after landing Yasuo gains a huge
long-lasting armor penetration buff that
affects enemy champion bonus armor there
are two important aspects worth pointing
out here first last breath suspends and
strikes all airborne enemies in the area
near yah suppose target second yossel
can capitalize on any knock of ability
with last breath bacon weave spinner
guys extremely well with champions like
Jonna last breath is an extremely
powerful ability with a potential to
turn the momentum of any fight here
Yassa was able to chain is alt with mal
fights initiation to safeguard such one
he's retreated let's have a look at a
few of yahwah's ability combos before we
get in the game play the first is a
simple Lane harassed combo after filling
your flow Barre lead in with e to dash
through the minion line and close the
gap with your lane opponent land your
queue before dashing back through the
minion wave using your passive shield to
help you in the trade next is an all-in
kill combo after priming your first q on
minions use your e to close the gap and
strike again with a mid dash Q which
guarantees a fully primed whirlwind
continuing your pursuit chain your
Rowand into your ultimate
before casting a final q thanks to its
low cooldown this come was especially
effective mid game to go in on your lane
opponent once the Ottawas passive shield
has been popped you have a short window
of opportunity to trade with your
opponent's range champions can trigger
the shield with relative ease before
hitting you with hard-hitting spells
successful Yasuo players will be
decisive in either trade back or retreat
before the shield expires when entering
a fight look for opportunities to block
off ranged enemies with wind wall while
you pursue your target with zigs out of
the way Yasuo tags the movement with
several cues as he waits from the pass
through the choke point leading back to
mid lane once there Yasuo can easily aim
his whirlwind and secure the kill with
last breath the range in yah suppose
whirlwind offers great reengagement
potential after roaming bought for a
seemingly unsuccessful gank yes what
readies his third q before retreating
seeing jinx head back into Lainey
quickly dashes through a minion to line
up a long-range whirlwind and re-engage
with last breath by leveling up steel
tempest in building attack speed Yas was
able to stack his Q much faster through
the abilities reduced cast time and cool
down once the ass was in arrange to land
his first cube his cast time is so level
that he can essentially use the ability
while moving helping him keep up and
secure the kills with his whirlwind
gospel gets the most from his ultimate
when used early in teamfights after
successfully repositioning himself among
the enemy squishies EOS will use
armor penetration does significantly
boost as damaged through the course of
the fight steel tempest is on such a low
cooldown that yossel can incorporate the
ability into his standard attack pattern
while finishing off Garen Yas will use a
sweeping blade to dodge Oregon his fall
before catching her with his second naka
had Yasuo used wind wall here to absorb
Caitlyn's attacks he might have survived
the fight and earned himself a pentacle
when building Yasuo there were a few key
stats that are central to his kit and
play style movement speed attack speed
critical strike chance in defense
critical strike is doubly effective on
Yas whoa thanks to his passing and
movement speed lets him stick to enemies
and refresh his shield more frequently
this makes static Shiva great early
purchase especially since sweeping blade
refreshes the items charges attack speed
directly affects the cooldown and cast
time of steel tempest allow him to use
his whirlwind and combos earlier in
fights finally as attractive as high
damage builds are yas will absolutely
needs defensive items to survive in the
late game a Rand one's omen or banshees
veil helps the Osmo stick to his enemies
while providing much needed durability
thanks for tuning in to the Yasuo
champion spotlight please subscribe to
the Riot Games YouTube channel and leave
us your comments just below the video
you